It is not an unusual sight in Iran:
a large conference attended only by men.
After all, women are to be hidden
from public view,
kept uneducated, silent, powerless.
It is within these strict confines
that a young woman,
eyes bright with possibility
for a more just and equitable world,
bravely steps into this gathering of men
with her veil removed.
Her face is uncovered,
an act considered blasphemous.
Just the presence of this woman alone
sends shock waves through the crowd.
She declares that the time has come
to break away from antiquated traditions
and step into a new era
of human consciousness,
in which every person is free
to choose their own path.
Soon after, she is imprisoned,
charged with spreading corruption on Earth
and sentenced to death.
This woman was Táhirih.
A poet, a mystic,
a champion for human rights.
Now, this story may sound
like a recent headline from Iran,
but it actually took place
nearly 200 years ago, in 1848.
When I look at my birthplace
of Iran today, I have to ask,
what's changed?
Have we made any progress?
I see Táhirih's fate being replayed
in the lives of other courageous women
who at this very moment
are choosing nonviolent means,
such as speaking out
and removing their hijabs,
to proclaim their freedoms.
And tragically, just like Táhirih,
their lives and the rights
they are defending
are being stamped out and suffocated.
It's easy to feel hopeless.
It's easy to feel defeated.
Yet within their stories,
and within hers,
I do see progress.
I see powerful lessons about what it means
to believe so deeply
in the transformation of society
that we dedicate our lives to laying down
the building blocks of a better world.
A world we may not even live to see.
Táhirih's life is an example
of being undeterred
by our limitations and our constraints.
In an arranged marriage
since the age of 14,
and with three children,
Táhirih still used whatever tools
she had within her means --
her words, her actions, her poetry --
to encourage all of those around her
to abandon the suffocating scripts
that they had inherited for their lives,
and to independently investigate
the truth for themselves.
She was met with hostile opposition,
abuse and imprisonment.
Yet Táhirih was unflinching
in her efforts,
fixing her eyes on a horizon line
of justice and freedom for all.
Through Táhirih's actions,
we understand the power that sacrifice has
in awakening a collective consciousness.
Though much of her writing and her poetry
was destroyed after her death,
her legacy could not be extinguished.
So many hearts were transformed
by the teachings that she spread,
and the seeds of possibility
that she planted for equality and freedom
are now bursting through the soil of Iran,
as evidenced in these brave, youthful,
female-led protests
that erupted following the tragic death
of Mahsa Jina Amini,
the 22-year-old Kurdish Iranian woman
who died in police custody
after being arrested
for improperly wearing her hijab.
Now today, when I hear that rallying cry,
"woman, life, freedom,"
I can't help but hear Táhirih's last words
before she was executed,
taken in the middle of the night
and strangled with her own scarf.
She said,
"You can kill me as soon as you like,
but you cannot stop
the emancipation of women."
"You can kill me as soon as you like,
but you cannot stop
the emancipation of women."
Táhirih's legacy
invites each of us to consider
what is fueling our own activism.
Her words and actions,
though radical and upending,
were not born out of bitterness
or hatred, or fueled by self-interest.
It was Táhirih's deep love for humanity
that propelled her forward.
And therein lies our challenge.
Can we stand up
against oppression and injustice
while deeply rooting our thoughts,
our words, our actions
in compassion and love?
Táhirih's life teaches us that we must act
with urgency and conviction,
while recognizing that we may not live
to see the fruits of our efforts.
We cannot expect immediate gratification
in our pursuit of justice,
because the transformation of society
is a multigenerational endeavor.
So what can we do?
We can take to heart
Táhirih's trailblazing example,
and in every moment,
we too can bravely choose
to do the next right thing,
knowing that we are planting seeds
that will grow into trees
under whose branches future generations
will find justice and peace.
I want to end with a poem of Táhirih's,
translated from
its original language of Farsi,
not only because it feels like
it could have been written today,
in light of all the conflicts
we are witnessing with broken hearts
all around the world,
but also because she offers us
a clear and poignant call to action
at a time where
we might be asking ourselves
what we want our legacy to be.
"Let warring ways
be banished from the world.
Let justice everywhere its carpet throw.
May friendship reconcile ancient hatreds.
May love grow from the seed
of love we sow."
Thank you.
(Applause)